je fais appel
citoyens russes au personnel
forces armées chargées de l'application des lois
corps et services spéciaux aux soldats et
aux commandants qui combattent actuellement
repousse les attaques dans leurs positions de combat
ennemi
ils le font héroïquement, sachant encore aujourd'hui
une fois dans la nuit, j'ai parlé avec les commandants de tous
directions
Je m'adresse également à ceux qui ont été trompés ou
menacé de se lancer dans une aventure criminelle
poussé sur la voie d'un crime grave
rébellion armée et donc actions
qui a divisé notre unité
essentiellement l'apostasie de son peuple de
camarades qui se battent
maintenant, à l'avant, c'est un coup dans le dos
pays et notre peuple